Julian was told he had a brain tumor
when he was just 28 and the prognosis
wasn't good it was a terminal diagnosis
so they gave me six to 12 months in
2016. now 34 he's outlived all medical
expectations but the former football
coach is unable to work and relies on
State financial support spiraling prices
mean he now worries about how to pay for
the basics I'm trying to live as good as
I can with whatever time I have left but
how can I do that if I'm wondering about
my the cost of living going up you know
I'm having to choose between food for
the week or petrol for a Hospital
appointment extra heating costs
medicines travel it all adds up and for
people like Julian can mean many
hundreds of dollars more on top of their
usual expenditure
and now add to that the cost of living
crisis the price of electricity gas and
food Rising steeply Little Wonder then
that a quarter of all young cancer
patients are now drowning in debt
sleeping behind on mortgages rent and
energy bills
the list trust governments put economic
growth Center Stage announcing massive
tax cuts to Turbo Charge the economy
paid for from debt-funded borrowing we
need to get Britain moving the markets
though reacted badly the pound falling
to an all-time low against the dollar
with thousands of mortgage deals pulled
as borrowing costs soared but despite
abandoning its top rate of tax cuts on
the highest earners to help calm the
markets most of the government's other
48 billion dollars in tax cuts remain
intact raising dire warnings of big
spending cuts to public services to help
pay for it and fears the government will
fail to increase things like disability
and unemployment benefits in line with
inflation children pensioners low-income
pensioners and the severely disabled
suffer the most because they can't work
to make up the difference between lower
payments and higher prices it means more
hunger it means more people going cold
in their homes over this winter and it
also fundamentally will mean more death
as well we now know the real cost of
past austerity measures findings
released this week claim there were more
than 330
000 excess deaths linked to government
Cuts in public services and benefits
introduced by previous British
governments between 2012 and 2018 people
dying prematurely because of reduced
incomes ill health poor nutrition and
housing
good boy there is a human cost to some
government decisions as vulnerable
people like Julian brace for a difficult
winter a reminder that the health of the
country's economy and its people are
inseparably linked Neve Barker Al
Jazeera London